this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode he's taking another
look at the guns of team fortress 2.
seriously we've shown him almost
everything this mad game has to offer
and he's survived so do you remember
when we showed you tf2 previously and
there was a jar yep let me through yep
the syringes are full of the same thing
what piss it's basically a piss a sniper
rifle
how lovely if you want to see more of
jonathan reacting to the guns of team
fortress 2 make sure to subscribe as
we've got two previous videos on valve's
classic shooter and if you'd like to
help out the royal armies museum and
continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
has been added
what do we have here then this is a very
short sawn off shotgun i'm not sure what
the
notches in the barrels are for they
almost look like wire breakers sometimes
shotguns certainly on some rifle have
notches to let you put barbed wire in
them and then you blow the wire open
with whatever ammunition is in your gun
um clearly that's not what they're for
here i think they're just a stylistic
choice there's another another odd
design key at the back there where the
barrel meets the bridge it's sort of
notchy but not open thankfully because
that would be
probably bad it's sort of it's got a bit
of a homemade vibe to it i think that's
just the crude art style to be fair and
then the really obvious feature
underneath which i thought was going to
be some kind of a launcher seems to just
turn the whole gun pink and increased
its power
it's one of these uh i suppose it's a
classic team fortress gun in that it
looks pretty much like a real gun albeit
through the lens of i don't know warner
brothers or something but it has a weird
thing attached to it that does weird
stuff i think that's a fair summary and
then one final word on realism as it
were there's a break open lever on the
top of the of the model doesn't look
robust or enough to actually function
and in fact the character just kind of
fudges his thumb across the lever
doesn't really seem to do anything with
it but that doesn't seem to be how it
breaks open
[Applause]
this is a really weird gun so this has
the um the lever and the general kind of
vibe of this the winchester 1887 the
famous
lever operated shotgun this one's a 10
gauge or 10 ball but it's only really in
the lever and maybe in the butt stock
the rest of it is well it's weird so
it's got a sort of browning auto five
hump on the back there which the ats
1887 really doesn't it's a
just a constant curve there housing the
the hat the sort of semi shrouded hammer
and the breach the weird drop out at the
bottom of the gun breach mechanism which
you you would have seen before i'm sure
but yeah very very strange so it's got
features of at least two real guns and
then it goes crazy so
we have a drum magazine on this thing
and only one barrel but we're cranking
the lever
three times and then we're firing three
shots i don't really get how that would
work i mean a lever with a drum i guess
you could use the lever to advance the
drum magazine and [ __ ] the weapon that's
plausible i don't think anyone's done
that lever action guns typically will
have a tube magazine some have a box
magazine on the bottom i don't think
anyone's seen the need to try and do a
drum okay i am i am now getting the the
baby face reference so the drum magazine
is reminiscent of the thompson
submachine gun we've got a bit of tommy
gun here so tommy gunn
smashed into 1887
with a bit of browning also five thrown
in it's always fun to try and spot the
the possible inspirations for these
things
right so this i gather is the stock
pistol and it seems to be a pretty much
a macaron pm a russian pistol based or
soviet pistol i should say based on the
uh volta ppk it's sort of it's going to
look a little bit like both of those now
a few quirks with this thing
right away the slide doesn't move now i
have criticized games before for having
a slide that moves too slowly this just
doesn't move at all so it's a little bit
old-school in that respect the hammer
doesn't move either we have a nice
visible ejection port on the left side
of the gun relatively unusual most users
being right-handed ejection ports are
typically on the right side or on the
top or somewhere in between the two and
then the reload is also very strange
flipping the gun forwards
sort of throwing the magazine out and
then slapping in a magazine from the top
is a pretty
idiosyncratic and rather unsafe way
to reload a firearm because it's going
to be pointing at you when you slam the
magazine in and because it's spinning
around your firing finger your fingers
going to be on the trigger when you slam
the magazine in and it wouldn't end well
finally finally
the sights are quite odd it has a gutter
on the top pocket pistols close combat
pistols sometimes do have gutter sights
and sometimes both so a tiny little
front sight within the gutter for more
precise aiming but then which case is
usually a proper notch rear sight as
well this has a big chunky front sight
sitting within that sight channel and
then no sight at the rear so kind of
making the
instinctive aiming potential of the
gutter a bit irrelevant and then making
precise aim impossible because the front
sight is gigantic and it has no rear
sight but again
this is me analyzing this thing as
though it were real and you have a
perfectly serviceable reticle in the
middle of your hud
okay i was completely off with my
imagination that this was some kind of a
laser for an air dropped attack or an
airstrike as a name might imply this is
as i probably should have realized one
of a family of weapons in team fortress
where it's generically a rocket launcher
so you can shoot it just like a normal
rocket launcher it even has the the
weird shoving multiple rounds from the
front reload that the others that i've
seen in the game do it's styled like it
like in a weapon but actually all it is
is it's better when you're in the air
the name is still valid just i was
reading too much into that so when
you're um launched up into the air rate
of fire certainly increases it is not
what i thought it was
okay i have to immediately
pause to say this is
somewhat visually and certainly in the
name
an alien reference as i'm sure i hope
all of you have already spotted this is
a reference to the flamethrower
incinerate incinerator unit as aliens
calls it from the original alien movie
i'm not sure when a palmer comes in i
mean yes flamethrowers do project
effectively napalm so it's just an
alternative term for flamethrower in
this case it's a bit busier than the one
from the movie but it definitely it's
definitely reminiscent of of that one
i've just had a flashback guys to the
canon weapon
from
fallout because this is a similar kind
of idea but whereas in that game we had
a like a metal frame and a rotating
cannon within it that you would then
load from from the muzzle this is in
some ways more conventional it's kind of
like a cross between a cannon
and a blunderbuss with a what looks to
be a
fuse sticking out of the breech i'm
gonna be intrigued as to how that works
let's have a look and see how this thing
actually works
so actually a breach loader there's
another kind of dump in the rounds
reload although at least it's going in
the breach end this time and that the
thing on the back is indeed a fuse but
it kind of magically lights itself the
player character is not lighting the
fuse the fuse just lights presumably
when you pull the trigger this is much
more of a cartoon cannon and the fact
that you open it up like a breech loader
though there are breech loading guns of
well going right back to the 15th
century actually with reloadable
chambers that look like giant beer
tankards that you fill with the charge
and you put the the shot up the barrel
in front of them stick the breech in
behind with a wooden wedge and make sure
that's nice and tight wrought iron
breech loaders we call those so we've
breached loading cannon right from the
earliest times they were you couldn't
get a good seal on them they were
cumbersome it was just easier to go to
muzzle loading for the next several
hundred years pretty much i can't think
of any artillery pieces that hinge open
in this way probably are some weird
patients out there for that it would be
problematic for practical reasons to
have the breach drop as though you're
breaking open a shotgun breech loading
artillery pieces they will typically
swing out to one side it's much more
convenient to do it that
begins in way seconds
right i do recall the the big old sentry
gun from this game this is like a mini
version of it now the big the big issue
if this were a real thing and sentry
guns do exist by the way not yet for any
kind of infantry use they're for fixed a
defense of a fixed position and they're
they're pretty rare but but they are
remote weapon stations are common on
armored vehicles now but we have the
technology in theory to identify track
and engage autonomously enemy soldiers
so something along these lines would be
plausible it's just not really in use at
the moment and the major drawback of
this design for me would be the kind of
checkered hazard tape and the great big
reds
emergency services style flashing light
on the top of the gun that that makes it
an absolute dead giveaway to be attacked
and that is one of the problems with
fixed weapons installations like this is
when you're engaged by one you might
take casualties but you'll see where it
is and you'll counter attack and it's
it's dead in the game this is just a
sort of lighter more tactically flexible
version of a sentry gun
so this this character's secondary
weapon
is pump action shotgun from memory i
think it's loosely the ithaca 37 which
it seems as soon as you mentioned that i
think of vietnam first probably and then
aliens this version has the bizarre
gubbins mounted to the side of it that i
guess sort of conceptually links it to
the sentry gun so and we can see the
sort of status effect there of it
glowing blue immediately after the
sentry gun explodes and there's some
kind of a boost that you get there as a
sort of revenge thing yeah so thinking
about it that unit on the side of the
shotgun is some sort of uh it's got sort
of like a radio receiver on it and its
sole purpose seems to be an a canister
of energy and when the sentry gun dies
the receiver detects or transmits that
fat to the gun and the gun is
overcharged supercharged somehow it
makes it more effective i don't know why
if that were a real thing why you
wouldn't just have that as an option but
i guess there's only enough fuel in the
tank as it were for one go and when
would you need that most it's when your
your main force multiplier has been
taken out taken out so it does make a
weird sort of logical sense
on the face of it this thing is some
sort of tranquilizer gun it's got the
darts well syringes with flights on the
back of them such as we would see in a
tranquilizer rifle it's bolt action
which those often are but the the actual
effect of it so this this is reminding
me of the tf2
syringe gun which was just a weapon
remember rightly it didn't have any kind
of health effect or anything like that
and from what i've seen so far neither
does this thing it's more of a themed
nail single shot
bolt-action nail gun really i do like
the corks on the end of the syringes
on the end of the needles that's a nice
comedy touch there so remember when we
showed you tf2 previously and there was
a jar yep that we threw yep the syringes
are full of the same thing
what piss
it's basically a piss a sniper rifle how
lovely
oh dear so i had hope that the the infa
the now infamous jar of fluid i thought
that would be it for that particular
theme but no it seems that uh
my first impression was that this would
be some sort of tranquilizer gun not so
much uh those are syringes or like
tranquilizer gun rounds you know like
syringes with fletching on the back
effectively to stabilize them in flight
and it's pretty horrific to think about
it if this were a genuine thing because
presumably the needles can all the
syringes contain the urine and they then
stick into you which is
delightful
okay i'm very much enjoying the um
the special effect of this of this
weapon as it were which is labeled
crikey which is a very british slash
commonwealth term uh that's a a an
explanation of surprise or alarm
which seems fitting given that if my
submachine gun turned gold and had like
red electricity around it and suddenly
did more damage i might actually say
crikey myself the gun itself is pretty
pretty reminiscent of the tech 9 ap9
kg9 that lineage of really more of more
machine pistols although with a shoulder
stock fitted to it like this um i'd have
to call it a submachine gun not much
point analyzing the detail as ever with
tf2 but front sight it does remind me
very much of an mp5 so it's a game take
on a compact submachine gun
okay i'm breathing a sigh of relief i
can genuinely feel a slight sense of
relief because this thing looks like a
real gun and that gun is
the colt python it's got quite a lot of
detail correct we've got a an attempt at
the
colt pattern of cylinder latch which you
pull to the rear
to be able to
open the cylinder although in
this version it's on both sides which
doesn't make any sense but they just
mirrored it and it's pretty close in
just about every major
feature the only sort of iconically cult
bit that's not there is the shape of the
trigger guard which has this double
curve in it on nearly all colts which
isn't on this model but the lines are
there it's even got the three ribs of
this particular barrel length of the
python now the colt python is the 357
magnum flavor of the cult magnum family
if you want to look at it that way the
snake revolvers all named after various
venomous snakes
[Music]
and in use it's a pretty standard magnum
revolver the the character's grip is
somewhat questionable in the the real
gun has this hump in the frame which is
for the web of your hand and it's to
help deal with the recoil of the gun now
if you were to hold it with your hand
wrapped around that
usually called a knuckle if you had your
hand wrapped around that and you fired
the real thing
i'd be a little bit concerned well
depending on how strong your grip
strength is that you might get a bit of
hammer pain if you've got a reasonable
amount of strength you'd probably
prevent it from from flipping that much
anyway it wouldn't be a problem but not
the recommended grip for this type of
revolver
all right that's a really weird gun
clearly inspired by the
ray guns of well i guess the 1930s 40s
50s 60s where it or it basically looks
like a rocket ship that you hold in your
hand but usually when you when you
include like a sci-fi ray gun blaster
laser weapon in in a game it's
not my experience of memory it's usually
stupidly powerful or at least capable
this thing did not look incredibly
effective and had has a comedy uh pump
up action with a sort of pressure valve
readout on the side implying that it is
powered by air that you pump up with
your hand but then the energy blast it
shoots is energy so who knows how this
thing is supposed to work i think it
looks kind of cool um i'm not sure it
really sort of fits the the aesthetic
and i don't necessarily i don't know it
doesn't didn't look great
[Music]
another weird gun what a surprise now i
was thrown off by the dragon head on the
end of this thing and the name heater
initially and stupidly assumed it might
be some sort of flamethrower i say
stupidly because the term heater the
nickname heater has been a term for for
a firearm for quite a long time um so it
is a it is a term for a gun as opposed
to an incendiary weapon which this is
not this is basically the niche it fits
is really the sort of mini gun niche
within a game i would say although it
doesn't have the multiple spinning
barrels it has one barrel with a
ventilated heat shield on it and then
just a big ammunition container
underneath
and a rear grip but it pretty much
functions like a mini gun or a chain gun
there's a rear
sorry there's a front sight there that
is completely negated by the great big
dragon head on the front of it the
dragon head is super you might be
surprised to learn is a real thing on
firearms if you go far enough back on
artillery guns and on handheld firearms
as well we don't have any i don't have
any to hand but we have examples in the
collection here at the royal armories of
actual dragon heads
chiseled into the muzzle of a gun barrel
which if you think about it is a
tremendous amount of work you'd have had
to have started with a much larger bit
of
iron or steel and chisel the metal away
so that the dragon head is noticeably
bigger than the diameter of the barrel
it's a it's a heck of a lot of work but
then these are heavily decorated items
so so strangely enough there is a there
is a real aspect here that i very much
doubt anyone developing the game would
have been aware of although they might
have picked it up from
other from chinese weapons that they've
observed
where the gun does defy expectations is
and links it more firmly to the dragon
motif i suppose is
it's a machine gun but it's a machine
gun that sets you on fire so
so it's sort of an incendiary weapon in
a twisted tf2 logic kind of way
thank you as always for watching this
review of
the guns of team fortress 2 and i'm led
to believe
the final part so this is your lot guys
sorry but uh it has been fun
as always we do have a link in the
description if you'd like to help us out
here at the royal armouries with what we
do you can also check out our own
youtube channel
it's worth a look if you if you like
your firearms and we have various social
media outlets beyond that as well
twitter facebook instagram the usual and
if you can visit one of our three
museums you're very welcome to do so
thanks a lot
[Music]
you